faith Rogers and her parents Kelly
Rogers and pastor charles Rogers join us
only on CBS this morning thank you so
much for for joining us I think when you
hear part two there was so much in part
1 this is the reckoning how has your
life changed since this thing my life
has changed drastically some for the
better some for the worse it's
definitely been a crazy experience from
when I talked to you
two years ago to now things have changed
he's in custody so it's been feels like
a long time coming but it's only been
under two years does it feel like a
victory at all I mean especially again
mom honestly it doesn't like him being
in jail it doesn't stop my life from
moving forward it's never gonna stop me
being attached to him or the documentary
it's never gonna stop the backlash if
anything is kind of worse than since
he's in jail it's a whole bunch of angry
fans or so it really hasn't gotten any
better knowing he's in jail that's just
knowing he's out he's not hurting
anybody else but people who he hurt are
still being affected even though he's in
jail Kelly
pastor Charles you've you watched your
daughter deal with this backlash which
must have as parents must be extremely
difficult absolutely it's very difficult
to see your daughter hurt and when she's
just a very young person trying to live
her life and all of this attention she's
gotten has been a lot of negativity we
often worry about face well-being her
safety when she's out trying to live her
life you know many times she's attacked
verbally she's been attacked physically
on uh it's pretty traumatizing when you
think about how faith got into this
situation you know they're gonna be
people who watch who think the parents
had some role how do they not prevent
this how could they let their daughter
get involved in something like this when
you guys look back well first what do
you say to people who think that and
then second when you guys look back is
there anything you would do differently
in raising her to not have a case like
this I don't know that we would do
anything differently
all you can do you can't make choices
for your kids you can just only guide
them show them the way try to teach them
the right way to live and and and make
good choices but ultimately it's going
to be up to them
we are sales were young and we didn't
always make the right choices sometimes
our parents told us what was right and
what was wrong and sometimes we chose
wrong and there's always consequences
you know that's one of the things that I
that I teach my children is their
consequences for your choices your life
is a series of consequences that you've
chosen the three of you shared a look
when we were reading the statement at
the top of this from from one of our
Kelley's representative saying that
basically the girls in this docu-series
are out for notoriety
they've always been out for notoriety
tell me what was going on with that
exchange of glances it was just
something like I've learned to just like
kind of just laugh at at this point
because I've addressed it over and over
I can keep addressing it it's been a
keeping their out for money when other
people were with him and date ahead and
they got cars bag shoes
faith never got any of that that's never
what I wanted let me ask you something
here one survey found that 60% of black
girls experience sexual abuse before the
age of 18 and the Justice Department
says that for every black woman who
reports a rape at least 15 do not do you
think that the attention that has been
placed on our Kelly on the alleged
victims will help people come forward
we'll change that narrative absolutely
and I can just say that just because
before the documentary came out I was in
New York
filing trying to get charges against him
picked up and I went and one of the
detectives she was like why did you wait
that's the first thing she asked me was
how long ago was it and she was like why
did you wait and I could have easily
like got discouraged and walked away and
I'm like it's stuff like that and
people's words that really make you
second think what you do before you do
it but at the same time I knew okay
they're not gonna pick it up I'm gonna
try somebody else and eventually it did
get picked up and I'm involved in the
federal case anything they need me to do
I'm willing to participate in and help
beautiful justify yeah um if they ask me
then I'll do my part
what do you want to happen at his trials
he needs to go to jail forever there
needs to be no getting out no anything I
feel like it hasn't just been me so if
you want to just talk about the people
in the documentary let's talk about the
people that weren't in the documentary
it's a track record so even if it's not
justice for me for the next person
that's good enough and if I may that was
originally when we found out what had
happened and we consulted with attorneys
and whatever that was our objective
never was money or our objective was to
we knew that there was some other young
ladies there there were other victims
and by faith coming forward that that
was our objective originally just to
hold him accountable and to also we were
told that it would help in other cases
and and and actually free those young
ladies that he had at the time since my
understanding are no longer with him has
never been money we haven't gotten a
dime God have blessed us we work you
know we are in our living i daughters
well taken care of but there's a reward
of making a difference there is yeah yes
sir faith kelly pastor charles Rogers
thank you all for being with us thank
woman coming on the show
you